Good morning, everybody, and welcome to the second day of the California State Board meeting.
Seeing that all board members are present, Executive Director Allen, would you please
call the roll to establish a quorum?
Member Burr.
Here.
Member Fattah.
Member Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member McQuillan.
Member Navo.
Here.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member Rodriguez.
Here.
Member Rucker.
Vice President Strauss.
Here.
Member Son.
Member Quillan.
Here.
Member Gabbard.
Member Williams.
Here.
Member Jim.
Member Johnson.
Here.
Member Gabbard.
Member Williams.
Here.
You have a quorum.
Thank you.
So reporting at a closed session,
the Board discussed or took action
on the following legal matters,
Kayla J. versus State and Carrie K. versus State.
So today I have some general announcements.
Members of the public wishing to dial in for public comment
should view the live stream of the meeting
to know at what time we'll be asking for public comment
on the agenda items.
Public comment will be provided by dialing the phone number
and participant access code
and then following each of the operator's prompts.
When you are dialing in,
the callers will be added to a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers
when it's their turn to provide public comment.
We're gonna also ask you as the public,
when you call in for public comment,
please turn down your speaker volume of your computer
if you're following us on the live feed
so that we don't get the echo effect
and then we'll be able to hear your public comment
that you've waited to give us.
And Board members, we're reminding you
to mute your microphones when you're not speaking
and keep your cameras on as much as possible
to ensure we maintain a quorum
throughout today's virtual meeting.
For each item, there'll be an opportunity
for Board members to raise your hand
using the Zoom participant window
if you'd like to make a comment or ask a question.
Today we are taking item 11.
Item 11 is a public hearing regarding a petition
for the renewal of a charter school
currently under the oversight
of the State Board of Education
pursuant to California Education Code 47605.9B,
consideration of PrepaTech Los Angeles High,
which was denied by the Los Angeles Unified School District.
The CDE recommends that the State Board
hold a public hearing to deny the request
to renew PrepaTech Los Angeles High,
a grade nine through 12 charter school
based on the CDE findings pursuant
to California Ed Code section 47605,
47605.9, 47607E, 47607.2B,
and California Ed Code of Regulations
Title V, section 119675.
This item will be presented by Stephanie Farland
from CDE.
Stephanie, I turn it over to you.
You may begin.
Thank you.
Good morning, Vice President Strauss,
members of the Board, Deputy Superintendent Gregson.
Today we are going to hear the appeal of the renewal
for PrepaTech Los Angeles High School.
So PrepaTech Los Angeles High School
is operated by, let me get my screen right here,
so I can see, is operated by Alta Public Schools,
a charter management organization
that also operates two other schools
within the LAUSD Los Angeles Unified School District.
PrepaTech is seeking authorization
from the State Board of Education
to renew their grade nine through 12 charter school
within the boundaries of LAUSD.
The petitioners initially saw authorization from LAUSD,
and on December 9th, 2020,
LAUSD denied the petitioner's request for renewal
by a vote of five to zero.
The petitioners submitted their petition
to the California Department of Ed
on appeal on January 8th, 2021.
Today, this Department of Education is recommending
that the State Board hold a public hearing
and deny the request to renew PTLAH,
a grade nine through 12 charter school.
At the April 13th, 2021 meeting,
the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools, ACCS,
voted unanimously in favor of the CDE's recommendation
to deny renewal of PTLAH.
The first time the ACCS has voted unanimously
in favor of denial, at least in the last several years.
Pursuant to Ed Code 47605.9B,
if the State Board chooses to grant renewal
of the petition pursuant to 47607,
the State Board shall designate in consultation
with the petitioner, either the governing board
of the school district or the Board of Education,
in which a charter school is located
as the chartering authority.
If approved by the SBE today,
the CDE is recommending that LAUSD be designated
as the chartering authority.
I do want to note that we did consult with the charter school
and they did request that the LA County Office of Education
be there authorized to approve the charter school.
Be there authorizer, should the State Board approve.
The department did have a discussion,
we are required to consult with them,
but felt that because LAUSD already has two other,
of the ALTA public school schools within their oversight,
that it made more sense for this school
to be under LAUSD as oversight,
especially as most of the recommendation today
is based on fiscal concerns.
The educational program of PREPATEC,
the mission of PTLAH is to provide a real-class education
to every student through an inquiry
and investigation school model that will prepare students
to meet the challenges of a global 21st century.
PTLAH is an authorized public
international baccalaureate diploma program school in LAUSD,
which affords pupils the opportunity and access
to a small, rigorous high school in their neighborhood.
The 2019-20 school year was the first year
11th graders participated in the two-year IB program
at PREPATEC at the end of this year, 2020-21 school year,
PTLAH will have their first group of pupils
eligible to receive the IB diploma.
The CDE's findings and concerns.
The department was unable to determine if PTLAH
met the applicable academic renewal criteria
pursuant to Ed Code 47607B based on California assessment
of student performance and progress, CASP, scores,
as a charter school only has one year of data
and does not report any colors
of the student performance and progress assessment
data and does not report any colors
on the California school dashboard.
The year we have, as it is for most schools,
2018-19 on CASP, 25% met exceeded standards in ELA
and 3% met or exceeded standards in math.
It is a high school, so as you remember,
they only test 11th graders.
So it did take a couple of years to get to a point
where they could test and this is the only year we have.
The CDE also reviewed the following verified data
that the petitioner included and provided
as criteria for charter renewal.
The California dashboard data for ELA math,
chronic absenteeism rates, suspension rates,
and English learner progress indicators.
They also submitted Northwest Education Association,
NWEA measurable academic progress data,
so map data, so we do have that included in the item.
In terms of their dashboard data,
remember there are no colors because they only had a year,
but the 2019 California school dashboard
reflects their performance
under California's accountability system as follows.
ELA is 65 points below standard
and math was 169.8 points below standard.
The ELA dashboard is a high school,
so it does not report any colors of the student performance
and does not report any colors of the student performance.
ELA is 65.8 points below standard.
Are you hearing feedback from my microphone?
Okay, I'm just hearing it then.
I hear myself being repeated.
California school chronic absenteeism graduation rates.
The dashboard does not show chronic absenteeism rates
for PTLH because it is a high school.
Don't gather that information for high schools.
The California school dashboard didn't,
also does not show graduation rates for PTLH
as it did not have a graduating class until 2020.
As far as suspension rates,
in 2018 they had 6.5%, which put them in the red,
but they did improve significantly in 2019,
moving to blue in one year.
The 2019 California school dashboard was the first year
the LP was reported.
The LP is calculated based on a student's performance
on the English language proficiency assessments
for California, the LPAC.
The data for the 2019 LP shows that 43% of PTLH
English learner pupils are making progress
towards English language proficiency.
In terms of the NWEA map data for reading an ELA,
if you remember from yesterday, reading an ELA,
we're in two separate slides.
So we take the data and the assessment data
that the school provides us,
and the school provided us with reading an ELA combined.
So it may look a little different than yesterday.
This is a winter to winter NWEA ELA four year comparison
for the class of 2020.
And you can see that in some areas they went up,
in some areas they maintained their scores.
And these are scale scores for overall student progress
towards mastery.
And then the next slide is there,
and oh, go, thank you, NWEA map data, this is math.
And again, you can see they stayed pretty constant.
English learner progress indicator,
these are LPAC results in percentages.
38% progressed at least one level.
4.7 maintained their level four designation.
33% maintained their level one through three H designation
and 23.8% decreased at least one level,
which comes out to about 57% maintaining or decreasing.
So the department's findings and concerns
specific to fiscal.
So there has been communication regarding fiscal concerns
over the life of this petition.
As stated before, it is an SB authorized school.
So has been under the oversight of the department
and the state board for the last several years.
It is noted that over the course of its oversight,
the SBE has issued five letters to prep attack
outline the following fiscal concerns,
negative fund balances, no reserves.
Although prep attack has responded to all letters
of concern with seemingly sound plans
to address fiscal issues,
the school has remained in poor financial condition
throughout the term of its current charter.
So there were five letters of concern
that were sent to prep attack
over the course of its current charter.
And although they responded every year,
they were back on sort of the fiscal concern list
and have stayed on there.
The annual reports that the board gets
of all of its SBE charters every year
regarding academic and fiscal health,
they have been on the poor fiscal list
for the entirety of their petition.
PTLAH has a poor financial records,
it's approval in 2016.
The prep attack's fiscal year 2021,
second interim report dated March 15th
indicates that PTLAH is projecting
a negative ending fund balance of 322,000.
The fiscal year 2019-20 audit report
reflected an unqualified status
with a negative ending fund balance
of 423,000 with a zero percent reserve.
And just so as we're kind of going through this,
and I often need to sort of relearn this
every time we talk about fiscal and budget issues,
that there is a difference between
ending fund balance and ending cash balance,
and we're gonna talk about both of those.
Ending fund balance is the net asset,
so the difference between total assets
and total liabilities.
The formula is beginning fund balance
plus or minus operating surplus or operating deficit.
Ending cash balance of a cash flow statement
equals the cash amount shown on the balance sheet.
Cash flow is the change in the charter school's cash
from one period to the next.
So pursuant to Ed Code 47607E,
and this is something that was implemented post 1505,
this is part of AP 1505 legislation,
the CVE provided notice to Prepatech
of its findings that Prepatech is demonstrably unlikely
to successfully implement the program
set forth in its petition
due to the following substantial fiscal factors.
Prepatech reported a 0% reserve
in the 2021 first interim report,
and per PTLAH's memorandum of understanding
with the state board,
Prepatech is to maintain a reserve of 5%.
Prepatech reported a negative ending fund balance
of 274,000 in the fiscal year 2021 first interim report.
They were given an offer, it's a 30-day notice,
so they were given an opportunity to correct,
to submit a cure and correct, submit corrective actions.
As of October 31, 2020,
Prepatech's net assets are negative 952,241
and their debt ratio is 2.34,
which means that PTLAH's total liabilities
are approximately 2,000.
So they were given an opportunity
to cover its total liabilities
are approximately two times the value of its total assets.
Furthermore, PTLAH's working capital ratio
would drop to 0.18, which means that they have,
they would have no current assets
to cover its current liabilities.
They did respond on April 2nd to our 30-day notice.
The fiscal corrective action plan provided by Prepatech
contained three main plans
to address the negative ending fund balances,
receipt of the payroll protection program loan of 470,000,
applying for COVID-19 relief funding
and increasing student enrollment.
Additionally, PTLAH noted that it expects
to increase its reserve to 5% by 21-22.
The CVE's analysis of their response,
we reviewed all the information submitted to PTLAH,
by PTLAH in response to 30-day notice.
We acknowledged that they tried improving
its fiscal condition and its updated
multi-year financial plan reflects
a projected positive ending fund balance of 165
for fiscal year 2021 with a reserve of 2.9%.
However, they still failed to meet the required 5%
outlined in its MOU.
They have not maintained the 5% in its reserves
since its inception.
A big piece of how they're trying to improve
their fiscal condition really was their PPP loan,
which provides them some cushion for the next year,
for the next couple of years.
In addition, Prepatech relies heavily
on short-term financing to the tune of 646,000
in fiscal year 2021 to cover a cash shortage
regarding repayment of the short-term financing.
It appears that PTLAH may incur a high financing cost
with factoring, adding an additional
negative effect to their budget.
The CDE concludes that although the response
partially remedied some of the violations
noted in the CVE's letter,
they still are projected to have some issues
with the 5% outlined in its MOU of reserve
and quite frankly failed to provide
any long-term fiscal structural changes
that will prevent the school from experiencing
similar fiscal deficiencies in future years.
As I said before, the PPP loan really was something
that they relied on in this budget
to in their response letter sort of get them over the hump,
but they've not made any changes structurally.
And we've seen over the last five years
that we've sent many response letters of concern
and still they have fallen short fiscally.
So we did, and you probably hopefully saw it
because in your documents that you received,
but the school did submit a new budget
just a couple of days ago.
And although it was very, very last minute,
we tried to go through it and see if there were any changes.
Mind you that this is a budget that LAUSD did not see
nor did ACCS and there were some unexplained differences
in this fiscal plan that we couldn't explain,
there weren't explanations attached to it.
So some of the discrepancies we have here,
and this is just a difference
between the report they turned in this week
and the report from March that went to the ACCS.
Their enrollment changed a little bit, it went up 22.
I'm not really sure how or why their federal funding
from the March report to the May report
went up almost a little over half a million dollars
and there's no explanation as to why that is.
Local funding went down, professional consulting fees,
that minus 142,000 is a one-time reduction
in their payment to their central office.
So a one-time reduction in the payment
they normally give to all two public schools.
They're not, I'm guessing not paying it once,
maybe in the coming year or this year,
I'm not sure about which year that that reflects.
And then their payment on debt,
they had an additional 12,000 dollars
they had initially projected a $58,000 payment in March
and now they're projecting a $457,000 payment.
Not clear where that 400,000 difference is coming from.
So there were some differences
and I'm sure that they'll be able
to answer questions on this,
but it was not clear in what they submitted to us
how some of these changes have come about
or whether they're long-term structural changes
or just one-time changes.
Next slide.
Additional fiscal concerns.
As I've said, since its inception,
Prepatech has demonstrated poor financial management
and has relied heavily on borrowing to cover its expenses.
It's unclear to us how all two public schools
have supported Prepatech in regard
to their fiscal expertise and financial planning.
It definitely is part of the consult,
the fee that is paid every year to ALTA
and from what I understand and from what they have said,
that covers fiscal management.
PTLH nor ALTA public schools has provided the CDE
or the state board with a plan to manage or cut expenses
to meet their fiscal uncertainty.
And I will say that in the ACCS meeting,
the commissioners had questions about this
and a lot of concerns from some of our charter operators
on the commission and charter staff
as to why there's not ever been a fiscal plan
to actually cut expenses to help their fiscal health.
PTLH employs a large number of staff
for a very small student population,
23 teachers, three administrators,
two resource specialists and a council,
one counselor for about 350 students.
And so that most of their budget really is towards staffing.
The petitioner does not meet the renewal criteria
inconsistent with sound educational practice.
The petitioner does not meet the renewal criteria,
does not present a sound educational program.
While the majority of the educational program is sound,
there's some real key pieces that are missing.
The CDE finds that the lack of an English learner curriculum
is problematic and does not align
with a complete educational program.
So they do have a detailed intervention program,
but they do not have a curriculum,
an English learner curriculum.
Additionally, as a PTLH petition
does not include reasonable descriptions of all.
All the charter elements, the CDE finds
that the petition is not entirely consistent
with sound educational practice.
Our findings regarding charter elements.
The CDE finds that the petition
does not necessarily provide, as just mentioned,
a reasonably comprehensive description of element A.
There was element D in there,
and I will go into why I have that crossed out.
Additionally, the CDE notes that the following elements
could be strengthened, element J, suspension expulsion,
element N, dispute resolution,
and effect on authorizer and financial projections.
So as stated just a moment ago,
element A, which is description of educational program,
the CDE finds that prep petition
is not consistent with sound educational practice
as it does not present a reasonably comprehensive
description of the ELD program,
specifically regarding not having a required
California state standards aligned ELD curriculum.
The governance structure,
going into the ACCS meeting,
we had still not received
the required conflict of interest code
that needed to be submitted.
They did submit it a day before the ACCS meeting,
so they are now in compliance.
So the element D,
governance structure piece is something
that we can now say they're in compliance with.
The CDE finds that the prep attack petition
provides a reasonably comprehensive description
of element J and element N.
However, CDE notes these elements could be strengthened.
Pursuant to Ed Code section 47605C5J,
the prep attack petition is required to clearly state
that when an appeal relating to the placement of a pupil
or the manifestation determination has been requested
by either the parent or prep attack,
the pupil shall remain in an
interim alternative education setting,
pending the decision of the hearing officer.
Whichever occurs first,
unless the parent and PTLAH agree.
Otherwise, this is language that we find missing
in a lot of petitions that come forward to us,
so this would need to be changed
if this petition is approved.
Element N, we note that
per the request of the district,
the petitioner changed the language of this element
after submitting the petition to LAUSD.
In order to reflect LAUSD as an authorizer,
and there was just some discretion,
and honestly, with 1505 and the new language
about who's authorizer,
who the authorizer will be assigned to,
there definitely was some back and forth
about who actually needed to be listed here.
So it just needs to be corrected
if the charter petition is approved.
Effect on authorizer and financial projections,
the prep attack petition does provide
the required information and financial projections.
However, the CDE notes of the language
can be strengthened to specifically state the manner
in which administrative services of the school
are to be provided.
So for instance, they have two administrative providers
for the school.
Alta, which is their CMO, is one of the providers,
and we noted how much they receive,
I think it's 12% of their total funding.
But they also have another back office provider
called Charter Impact that receives
about $100,000 from the school.
And it was not clear in the petition
or any of the documents how,
what services, which specific services
that each of those entities provide the school.
So in conclusion, the CDE recommends
the State Board deny the request
to renew the PTLA-H petition.
As I said earlier, at the April 2021 ACCS meeting,
commissioners voted unanimously
to recommend denial of the prep attack renewal.
If the SBE grants renewal of the petition
pursuant to Ed Code section 47607,
the CDE is recommending that the State Board
designate the Los Angeles Unified School District
as the chartering authority for prep tech high school.
And that concludes my presentation.
So Stephanie, thank you so much
for a really specific and thorough presentation.
We are now going to open up the public hearing
at 10.02 a.m.
First, we're going to hear from the petitioners
representing the charter school
and each side will have 12 minutes.
So we'll ask our charter school representatives
to join us now, and then you may begin.
Hello.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Yes, we can.
Good morning, dear board members.
Thank you very much for the opportunity
to tell our side of the story.
My name is Mario Reyes.
I'm the founder and CEO of Alta Public Schools.
In 2015, we sought to start prep attack high school
at the behest of our parents that loved the school
and that loved the school and that loved the school
at the behest of our parents that love
the holistic approach of an IB education.
At that time, we made a promise to our parents
that their children would get a world-class education
and get them a college if we were approved.
In early 2016, we came to this board on appeal from LAUSD.
During that meeting, one SB board members shared,
not sure why you're here and voted for us
to start the school on the very same promise
we made to our parents.
Provide a world-class education to all students
and get them to college well-prepared.
Today, we want to affirm to those board members
and the families we serve, we kept our promise.
We are providing a world-class education to every student.
Our students are showing steady growth in ELA and math
over the current charter term,
as demonstrated by NWA scores.
Last year, with our first seniors,
we had a graduating class of nearly 90%
and 70% of those graduates are going to college.
This is an average greater than LAUSD and the state.
This year, we're projected to graduate 97% of our students
despite the pandemic and more and more of our students
are going to prestigious colleges and universities.
On our finances this year, we're also projected
to end the year with positive net assets of 300,000
and reserves of 5.5%.
But over the last five years,
it has not been a straight shot.
It's been more like the path of a butterfly.
After we opened our doors in the fall of 2016,
we opened with 100 plus students
and with no charter school startup grant funding
or any other kind of financing.
The second year, we doubled our enrollment
and moved to an LAUSD Prop 39 site.
Soon we realized that if we grow again
by another 100 plus students the following year,
the Prop 39 site would be inadequate for student stability
and undermine the IB program facility requirements.
Therefore, in order to provide education and stability
and equity to our students,
we were presented with a once in a lifetime opportunity
in the LA market, a permanent facility nearby.
We believe that if we invested early in a stable facility,
the benefits would be enormous for the community at large
in the long term.
So we borrowed to refurbish the facility
that the school occupies today.
This is our home behind me.
Our parents are very proud of their school
and how great it reflects on the positive impact
students are making in their community.
However, to prepare this stable home,
we had to secure financing,
borrow internally from our sister schools
and slowly build the reserves requirement.
At the end of that second year,
we reflected short and long,
both academically and financially.
We concluded that although the academic program was strong
and students were achieving,
we needed to engage financial experts
to achieve a balanced budget and gain reserves
and to ensure we would fulfill the promise
we made to the community and to this board.
This is why in the third fiscal year,
we contracted with charter school finance experts,
Spencer Stiles and Charter Impact
to help us create a multi-year plan
to get us back to good financial health
representative of a world-class school.
Here's Spencer Stiles to explain what he and his team
did for us with our fiscal austerity plan
to get us back on track.
Spencer.
Javier and good morning board members.
Thank you for your time and attention today.
Prior getting into some of the historical
financial activity of the school,
I do wanna clarify and point out
what I think is a pretty critical concept
and that is the fact that the school has
looking historically actually maintained
or hit that 5% ending fund balance,
which is clearly a significant concern.
I do think it is important to point out
just in terms of accuracy
that fund balance is a cumulative number.
And so as you can see on the screen in front of you,
the first two years of deficit
were large enough to create a goal,
which were then required three years
of balanced budgets and surpluses to overshadow them.
So while the school has not hit that 5% deserve
until the current year,
again, it is important to understand
that it is a cumulative figure
and the school has actually turned the tables
so to speak financially in year three,
as you can see with the annual surplus of 390,000.
Now to give a little historical context,
Carter Impact was in during the middle of year three
after the school had understandable concerns
over its fiscal operations, accuracy of forecasting
and readiness of financial reporting.
As a part of our initial engagement,
we'd review the internal control,
fiscal policies and procedures,
accuracy of forecasting and budgeting
and we're asked to come on board full-time
from the first of 2019 towards the end of year three.
As a part of our engagement,
we immediately changed the reporting process,
increased the accuracy of projections and budgets
and also sped up reporting to the board,
giving the schools the information and data necessary
to make the proper decisions for cost of solvency.
That does include providing financial reports
correctly to the board within 10 days after the end of the year.
Looking at the operations going through year three,
Javier did mention that there was a significant amount
of facility costs which led to that $150,000 deficit
with cumulative $880,000 negative fund balance.
In year three, those facility costs did not continue.
The Prop 39 site was eliminated as it was no longer necessary.
Staff levels were frozen in that fiscal year
with the exception of necessary instructions
stamped for classrooms.
The student ADA and enrollment increased by 15
and the result was a $390,000 surplus,
making a huge reduction of the negative fund balance.
In year four, a second site was added
to account for the additional six months
while the school reached full grade 9-12.
The school maintained the first degrees
on non-required instructional staff.
And again, as you can see,
the school maintained the balance budget
and had another surplus in year four of about $67,000.
In the current year, we are projecting
less than 45 days from now,
leaving with a surplus of $720,000.
As referenced, $400,000 did come from a forgiven PPP loan,
but even without that, the school was on target
to have an additional $300,000 surplus this year.
Please also note that that amount does include
all of the costs of all the current
and outstanding borrowing necessary
to overcompensate the referral.
Looking forward, while the school is projecting
the enrollment next year of 376,
it's also important to note that at this practice,
we also maintain multiple budget scenarios
based on the current enrollment as of today
to ensure that the school is not incurring any costs,
finalizing hiring or incurring anything else
that would potentially tip the school
back into the deficit until we have confirmation
that the enrollment number is reached.
And so with that, I will pass it over to Javier
to address the rest of the austerity measures
being focused on for the upcoming years.
Mr. Reyes, you may want to unmute yourself.
Thank you so much.
To be clear, we want to communicate to you
that we understand how severe the situation looked,
and we understand that operating in a deficit
is a main reason LAUSD denied our renewal last year,
despite their efforts from staff
to keep us open during the pandemic.
We sincerely thank LAUSD staff
for the positive recommendation to the current SBE board.
We can assure you that if given the opportunity,
we will continue to do everything we can
to make sure our finances continue to improve every year.
Moving forward, we will continue to work
with Spencer Stiles and his team
to continue to keep us on track.
We'll continue to work with Larson Communications
digital marketing experts
who continue to assist us with student recruitment.
We'll transition to utilizing a line of credit
from our bank instead of expensive short-term financing.
We will improve our fundraising capabilities and results
working with National Charter School Resource Center,
and we'll reactivate our LEA Medicare reimbursement program
to recapture special ed funding
of up to 50% of expenditures.
We'll identify liquid assets
in case of severe cash shortages in academics.
Here's Rachel Villalobos, Interim Superintendent,
to talk about academics.
Thank you, Mr. Reyes.
Good morning, Board President
and members of the State Board of Education.
In these short five years of existence,
we have had the opportunity through hard work
from students, parents, and staff
to become an IB World School.
We are one out of four IB DP schools
in the Los Angeles Unified School District region.
We are the only TK through 12th grade
to be an IB continuum organization
with the PYP, NYP, and DP IB program.
The slide that you see here is PrepaTech High
has both middle years and diploma program authorized,
which is part of the IB continuum.
100% of our students are IB students.
We have 100% of our students that are IB eligible.
Those who do not have an interest in the IB DP candidacy
by the time they get to your own grade
benefit from IB via theory of knowledge,
approaches to learning, learner profile attributes,
and community activity service.
It is my pleasure to introduce to you, Mr. Alqueda,
our high school's head of school principal.
Good morning, members of the board.
In 2020, 89% of our first group of seniors graduated.
Currently, we have 97% of our seniors projected
to graduate at the end of this year.
75% of the students who applied to colleges
have actually received acceptance letters.
In fact, 24% of those students have received
acceptance letters from two or more college and university.
And we agree with the staff report on pages three to 14
in which PrepaTech provided a reasonable comprehensive
description of the plan for low achieving
and high achieving pupils,
as well as meeting the AB 1505 middle performance criteria.
Our ELD program is comprehensive
and comprised of both integrated and designated ELD.
The IB program is committed to supporting multilingualism
as a fundamental part of increasing intercultural
understanding and international mindfulness,
and is equally committed to extending access
to an IB education for students from a variety
of cultural and linguistic background.
Thank you, PrepaTech.
Your time for public presentation is now over.
Thank you very much, Rita.
Thank you very much.
So now we will hear from the school district,
and the district will have 12 minutes as well.
Good morning, Vice President Strauss,
Deputy Superintendent Gregson, members of the SBE.
My name is Bob Perry, and today I'm representing
Los Angeles Unified School District,
where I serve as one of the leaders
of the charter schools division.
I'm joined today by three of the school district leaders,
and I'm going to introduce them.
First, I'm going to introduce you to Bob Perry,
who is the vice president of the SBE.
Bob Perry is the vice president of the SBE,
I'm joined today by three other members of our team,
our director, Joseco Gutierrez, Lillian Lee,
who leads our fiscal team that reviewed the petition
for PrepaTech, and Christian Mendez,
who leads the instructional operational team
that reviewed the petition as well.
We come today to support the recommendation
of the California Department of Education staff,
and the prior decision of the LAUSD Board of Education
for the denial of the renewal of this charter.
This school is currently operating within LAUSD's boundaries
and the district oversees its two sister schools,
Academia Moderna and PrepaTech Middle School.
Should the State Board of Education
deny the renewal of this charter school today,
please know that LAUSD is committed
to actively working with CDE staff
as the current authorizing staff and the charter school
to support all current students and families
to enroll at another LAUSD public school.
As we do with the closure of any charter school
within LAUSD boundaries, our team has an extensive plan
for ensuring the continuity of education for all students,
including, but not limited to,
working with the current authorizer and staff
to connect parents with local district staff
to explore all placement options that would be available,
such as international baccalaureate programs,
magnet programs, district pilot schools,
programs for students with disabilities
and charter programs.
Also making sure that current transcripts
and other relevant documents are thoroughly reviewed
to inform the best placement.
Regarding the detail of the item before you today,
much of our in-depth analysis was similar,
if not identical to that of the CDE staff
who has been their authorizer for the past five years.
So we will not go through that analysis again today,
but we'd like to provide you some context
for our recommendation and the board's ultimate decision.
Our review of this application came during the fall of 2020
when California was in the throes
of the worst part of the pandemic
without a clear path forward for reopening schools
for in-person instruction.
The situation was unprecedented,
as was our recommendation for a conditional approval.
Ultimately, after extensive deliberation,
the LAUSD board determined that a denial was warranted
and would be in the best interest of students
despite the pandemic circumstances.
One of the ways we address closure
being in the best interest of pupils
is by comparing data to the schools
the students would have otherwise attended
based on their addresses as provided by the school
and compiled by the LAUSD Office of Data and Accountability.
The data we used was the 2019 data
mentioned by the CDE previously.
I'd like to call on my colleague, Christian Mendez,
to briefly run through the overall comparison by metric.
And hello, good morning.
Good morning, board members.
A pleasure to be with you this morning.
As Dr. Perry has asked, I would like to share with you
a comparison of PrepTech Los Angeles High School's
performance compared to the median performance
of the 20 resident schools that students would otherwise
have attended based on their address.
So where data is available, I'll share out.
So in ELA, the resident schools median
is outperforming PrepTech.
Resident schools median is at negative four in ELA,
whereas prep distance from standard,
whereas PrepTech is at negative 65.7.
That translates into 17 out of the 20
resident schools outperforming.
Excuse me, in math.
Bad timing for a frog in your throat.
Okay, in math.
In math, again, the same story.
We see the resident schools median of 92.3
outperforming the charter schools
distance from standard of negative 169.8,
translating into 19 of the 20 resident schools
outperforming the school in math.
In LP, we see the converse,
where we see the charter schools, 42.9%,
outperforming the residents.
So here, we actually see the charter school
outperforming the majority of the resident schools.
Only five of total in the school here.
In suspension, we see that the majority of the schools,
19 of 20, outperforming the charter school.
The median suspension rate is 0.3 for the resident schools,
whereas PrepTech high schools is 1.5.
In reclassification, again, we see the same pattern,
that the resident schools,
the median is outperforming PrepTech high school.
So here, we see 19 of 20 resident schools
with a better reclassification rate than PrepTechs.
The median for the resident schools was 15.5,
compared to PREPA's 3.8, and this is 19, 20.
And then lastly, in both CASPLA and math,
we see the resident schools percentage
of students meeting and exceeding standards,
outperforming PREPA Tech highs.
In ELA specifically, the median for the resident school
met and exceeded percentage is 51.56%,
compared to PREPA's 24.47.
And in math, same story, in ELA,
that translates to 18 of 20 resident schools
outperforming the charter school.
In math, 19 of 20 resident schools
are outperforming the charter school.
The median performance for met and exceeded percentage
in math for resident schools is 19.62,
compared to 3.26 of PREPA Techs
meeting and exceeding standards in math.
So in summary, what we see is that
in the majority of the categories,
ELA, math, suspension, reclassification,
CASP, ELA, and math of meeting and exceeding standards,
we see that the resident schools,
majority of them are outperforming the charter school
with the available data.
I wanted to share that for your consideration.
Thank you, Dr. Perry.
Board members, I have not been before you for a while,
but have stood before you numerous occasions.
And I absolutely detest to ask you
to support a recommendation to close a charter school.
It's never easy.
But I'm here to assure you today,
as we've assured you in the past,
that we stand ready and experienced
to support students and families
if that is the decision of the board today.
We ask you to support the CDE recommendation
as well as the previous vote
of the LAUSD Board of Education.
Thank you so much for your time.
And we'll be here and available
for any questions you might have for us.
Thank you so much, Vice President Strauss.
Thank you, Los Angeles Unified Charter School Division Team.
So we will now open the phone line
for our public comment queue.
So members of the public wishing
to provide comment on this item may do so.
So let's put the slide up now
that we will be using for public comment.
When you call in, we're gonna ask you
to state your name and affiliation for the record.
And remember to turn down your speaker volume
of your computer if you're following the live feed
because otherwise we'll hear an echo.
You are gonna have one minute.
We do remind you to please be respectful.
And at this time, all comments are related
to the Prepatec Los Angeles High School Charter item.
And now I'm going to ask the Spanish translator
to read the, to translate the instructions
in Spanish for our callers.
Good morning.
At this time, public comments will begin.
The phone number is 712-770-4917.
And the access code is 467-9071.
Please, when it's your turn,
an operator will ask you in English
to state your name and affiliation
and to start your intervention.
Please say, my name is,
represento a, y necesito un traductor.
Su tiempo comenzar cuando empiece.
Muchas gracias.
So now we're going to open up for public comments.
Do we have any public items on the Prepatec Los Angeles
High School Charter renewal?
Yes, we have public comments.
Caller, please state.
Go ahead.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Good morning.
This is Walter Guzman.
I'm a resource specialist teacher
at Alta Public Schools Prepatec Los Angeles High School.
I would like to take this opportunity
to request that Prepatec Los Angeles High School
be renewed for another five years
due to several reasons.
Prepatec is a school that educates the whole child
using the international bachelor curriculum.
There are no other schools in the southeast Los Angeles area
that offer this international program
that educates students to be inquirers,
which is a skill set that is needed
in the future information economy.
This mindset is needed for many of tomorrow's leaders,
innovators and thinkers.
The education that is given at Prepatec High School
trains many students to be better thinkers
that will be better overall for our future economy.
Many of these students come to Prepatec High School
to earn college credit, experience small class sizes,
and to develop lifelong relationships
with both peers and staff,
an advantage that other high schools
in the area don't offer.
The progress is showing in the way more students
in the area graduate from Prepatec High School
and go on to good universities and colleges.
Thank you.
I request, please renew Prepatec Los Angeles High School
for another five years.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time begins now.
My name is Mark Nolan.
I'm a retired school administrator of 30 years
and I am now working with the Alta School District.
In my present position as an assistant principal,
I've had the opportunity to observe a team of educators
throughout the district that are dedicated
to the academic growth and social awareness of our students.
Our fledgling IB program provides this
to a group of students that normally
would not have a program of this stature.
And this was accomplished with a balanced budget
and a required reserve.
Alta's leadership understands the concept
of investing in our students now
and that we're actually investing in their future.
Thank you for listening to our petition
for renewal of Prepatec High School.
Hello, caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time begins now.
Hello, Barry Baxter,
Superintendent, Alta Public Schools, retired.
The IB diploma program offered by Prepatec High School
far outweighs the dismal district alternative
in regards to success in reaching higher level education.
Prepatec High School was designed
to include the IB diploma program
to allow students of this underserved community
a proven gateway to success at the college level.
Prepatec's current graduation rate of 97%
far outperformed district schools of the same service area
who averaged only 80.6% last year.
Without access to proven approaches
of the IB diploma program,
the students of this community are fated
to receive a typical district education
that has evidently lack of adequate preparation
for success in higher level education.
This charter renewal must be approved
to ensure the successful pathway to higher education
for the students of this community.
Thank you, board.
Hello, caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time begins now.
Are you there, caller?
What number is it?
We need translation, I believe.
Si, por favor, me diga su nombre
y la relacin del estudiante o de la escuela.
Buenos dias.
Si, me escucha?
Hello.
I can hear you, caller.
Okay, no lo podemos escuchar.
Tenemos una pregunta, seor?
Si, por favor, me diga su nombre y la relacin del estudiante o de la escuela.
Tiene, hello.
What's the phone number you're talking to?
The last four numbers of this call
are 2528.
Okay, that's me.
Thank you.
My name is Alejandro Muoz,
and the information regarding the IB program
is completely incorrect.
There are schools surrounding our school
that have maybe five, six hundred seniors
of which maybe 20 are IB students.
So it is in no way the same as the program
that we offer where about 80% of the students are IB.
So there is no place for these students to go
if they do not renew this program.
Please renew it.
Thank you.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello, board members.
My name is Elvia Delacruz,
and I'm a teacher with Pepatec Los Angeles High School.
I want to let you know we offer a rigorous curriculum
to students to prepare them for college.
Our team of dedicated teachers have done their best
to ensure students apply for this program.
Thank you.
For college.
Our team of dedicated teachers have done their best
to ensure students apply their knowledge feels necessary
to be successful citizens of the world.
Our international baccalaureate program is unique
in that it teaches our students how to be critical thinkers
open minded on global issues risk takers caring inquires
balanced knowledgeable communicators and principals
skills that not all neighboring schools are equipped with.
In turn many students of our senior class have been
accepted to best universities in the nation such
as John Hopkins University Duke Pepperdine Berkeley
and USC to name a few.
This speaks volume of our teachers and curriculum
here at Pepatec Los Angeles High School.
And our incoming students deserve the best education
possible that this school offers.
So please vote for you.
A great school to remain open.
Thank you.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Are you there, caller?
I am here.
One second, please.
I'm ready.
Tell me when to start.
Please begin now.
My name is Nestor Enrique Valencia.
I'm the former council member and mayor here
in the city of Bell.
And I am also a former vice president of the parent
advisory board for LAUSD.
It is very, very saddening to see these recommendations come
to this fine school.
We need a school like this in the southeast.
They're very dedicated professionals at this school.
I understand the legislation that puts forth the rules
and regs for protecting the public interest
and the interests of the students.
This is not the case in this school.
What I mean by that is this is not the reason
to end a charter.
This school has its challenges like any other school,
any other public school.
I could also tell you that this school is very
engaged in our community.
And it is a prime example of this community.
Thank you, caller.
Your time is up.
Thank you so much for your time.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Are you there, caller?
Hi, good morning, board members.
Can you hear me?
We can hear you.
My name is Jeanette Santana.
I am a proud parent of a prep-a-tech high school
student.
Caller, you're welcome to call back in.
We're not certain what happened on the line.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Are you there, caller?
Caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello, caller.
Good morning.
Can you hear me?
Yes, caller, we can hear you.
Good morning.
My name is Maria Gonzalez, and I represent three students
at Alta Public School.
I'm the mother of three children in the Alta Public
School system.
My eldest, who is now a freshman at a prep-a-tech high school,
has been a part of the Alta family for the past six years.
I cannot put into words the satisfaction and relief
we felt as a community, knowing that our children now
have the opportunity to have the complete academic
experience in the only school family some have known.
The added benefits of having an elementary, middle school,
and now a high school with an IB learner program
is something unique to this community.
Part of LA USD's mission statement
is that it will be a progressive global leader in education,
providing a dynamic and inspiring learning experience
where all students graduate ready for success.
Ladies and gentlemen of the board,
you have before you the opportunity
to prove this mission statement true today.
The renewal of this high school is an investment
in this community.
Doing so ensures a great successful future for our kids.
Thank you.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Good morning.
My name is Amelia Nguyen, and I teach language and literature.
This is my third year at Prepatech
and 10th year in education, and I want
to promote this school for renewal.
Bringing IB to this particular community
is a huge undertaking.
I hold a teaching credential and master's in education
from UC Davis.
Go Aggies.
But even with my previous training,
it is taking years of work and immense financial investment
to synthesize the many facets that make up an IB education
in a culturally responsive way that is specific to the needs
of our students.
When I started at PEPA, we struggled
to retain skilled teachers due to the pay
skill differences from surrounding districts.
Now that we are comparable, our teachers are staying
and learning the IB framework.
I can say with assurance that IB education here
at PEPA is amazing and Prepatech is the scrappiest
school I have ever seen.
Our test scores only show where we are starting.
And I love the IB framework because it aims
to serve the students where they are and help
them become global, thoughtful, and reflective citizens.
We have learned so much over the last five years
and the amount of growth I've seen in both staff
and students is immeasurable.
Thank you, caller.
Your time is up.
Thank you so much for your time.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Are you there, caller?
Hello.
You're there.
Can you hear me?
Yes, we can hear you, caller.
Good morning.
My name is Viviana Matamoros.
I am a community member for the past 30 years
and also work at Prepatech Middle School.
I am here to ask for your support to renew one
of our public sister schools, Prepatech High School,
as we have become officially one of the first
international baccalaureate K-12 school in LA district
that is free completely to every single student
that attends our school.
What does this mean?
For one, that the investment that the school has done
on facilities, IB trained teachers,
and other requirements for this program
was a great investment,
and it is starting to show with positive results.
We need to allow the school to grow to its full potential
and to keep in mind that great schools
are not just built in five years.
We are starting to bloom,
and it shows in the high percentage
of graduating students going to UC St. Cal State.
Here, every student is offered an opportunity
to be an IB student and dream big,
so they strive for a great future
and are able to have the American dream,
a great education for success.
Our kids and future generations for our community
deserve to have an IB school just as any world community,
and this is what we are asking for,
for you guys to renew the school
because our community deserves it.
Thank you, caller, your time is up.
And many of us have waited for this.
Thank you.
Hello, caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi, my name is Marissa Ruscon,
and I serve as the expanded learning program manager
with the Alta Public Schools.
Prepa Tech surrounds its students
with support, love, and guidance daily,
creating an environment that students can grow and flourish
with dedicated faculty and staff
that keep the needs of our families
at the forefront of every decision.
We invested time and resources
to ensure that all students are provided
with quality learning experiences and opportunities
to develop personally and academically.
Our IB program is one of four in LUSD
and brings a unique and special learning opportunity
to students by preparing them for success
in their next step to college and career
with a high graduation and acceptance rate
to a four-year college and university,
the highest in our community.
Prepa Tech is creating true global citizens
with the skills and tools needed
to impact not only in the Southeast LA community
but the world because Prepa Tech students have the pride,
the rigor, the leadership,
and the love for their family and community
to be the change.
Please consider the renewal of Prepa Tech High School
as not only an investment into the future of our students
but as an investment into our community.
Thank you, Paula.
Your time is up.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello.
We can hear you.
Yes, good morning.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can hear you.
Good morning.
Please give us your name.
Can you hear me well?
Can you give us your name
and the student's affiliation or the school's name, please?
Yes, my name is Marta Barajas
and I have two students in Prepa Tech.
One has two of her kids.
And the other one is in grade nine.
And the reason for my call is because I'm asking the board
members to please renew the Prepa Tech High School contract
because my kids have been there for a while.
Please wait a moment.
She's got two kids at the school
and she would like to request that the school be renewed.
Please continue.
Yes, the level of learning that my kids have had
in Prepa Tech High School is the same as in Prepa Tech High School.
The school is of high quality.
It's as if they had it in a private school.
And really, if you don't approve the renewal of the contract,
it would be terrible for me.
It's like knocking on my kids' door when they arrive at the university
because they are having an excellent education.
My kids have pure health and a program like this.
Please wait a moment.
She said that her kids are receiving an excellent education
there at the school.
Do you have more?
Yes, and I'm really desperate because now that I know they're not renewing it,
I ask you to please help my kids arrive at the university
by approving Prepa Tech High School.
Yes, please.
She would like to say that she wants the school to be renewed
so her kids can go to a university.
I travel from Long Beach to Huntington Park every day.
She travels from Long Beach to Huntington every day.
For 11 years.
For the last 11 years.
Please continue.
Yes, please.
They are excellent teachers of high quality, excellent staff,
and really, they listen to the voice of the parents,
not the people who are against it.
I am very happy with Prepa Tech High School.
Please wait a moment.
She just said that the teachers are excellent.
Thank you very much.
Please listen to the parents.
That's time. Thank you.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Linda Vargas.
As an Alta Public Schools employee,
I've had the privilege to work alongside dedicated staff,
but more importantly, our students and families.
Our students and families are so committed and eager to excel
and learn.
The rigor offered by our RB program is available to each
and every one of our students.
It is not exclusive to the families that can pay for it.
Why should our children not have the right to this program?
Tuition for another K-12 continuing school in the Santa Monica
area is approximately $21,000 per year.
Ninety-five percent of our families are socially, economically
disadvantaged and would be unable to afford giving their
children that type of education.
The early investment made for our new building early on is
evident within the Prepa Tech High School hallways where our
students find teachers and staff that encourage, motivate,
and push them past fears into greater heights.
Last year, our graduating class had an 89.3 percent graduation
rate.
I urge you to renew Prepa Tech High School and allow this
cocoon to flourish into the bright and beautiful butterfly
our community needs and deserves.
Thank you for your time.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Good morning.
My name is Julia Longo, and I am proud to be the diploma
program coordinator for Prepa Tech.
We are one of only a handful of IB schools in the LA area,
and there is no other continuing school in the area which
provides continuity of the IB curriculum from its primary
years and middle years programs to the diploma programs in
grades 11 through 12.
Unlike most schools, we do this at zero cost to our families.
This rigorous educational opportunity enables students to
enter four-year colleges with tuition credits equivalent up
to one year.
Not only our families, but the nationally and internationally
respected WASC and IB organizations have attested that
we are providing a quality education to our students.
Test scores do not demonstrate what is truly being achieved at
Prepa Tech.
The renewal of the Prepa Tech charter is in the best interest
of our historically disadvantaged students.
Thank you.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one moment.
Your time begins now.
Hello.
We can hear you.
Okay.
Hi.
My name is Naomi Cuevas.
I am the mother of a proud student who attends the high school.
As a proud parent, I am imploring the renewal of our high school.
I have firsthand experienced the growth that my daughter has had academically.
I moved my daughter from the Downey Unified to give her the
opportunity of this unique IB program the school offers.
This IB program the school offers is not offered anywhere else,
which I looked.
Prepa Tech Los Angeles is an important step in our low-income
community to have a chance to a better education, to a brighter future.
Let us remember our students are the future of this country,
therefore require the best education, and Prepa Tech offers that.
It will be crucial and devastating to our community and a great loss
if our children were to lose the opportunity.
Please consider the renewal for Prepa Tech High School.
Thank you very much for your time.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello.
Good morning.
Please repeat.
Please state your name and affiliation and don't forget to pause after each
sentence to be able to translate.
Yes, thank you very much.
Good morning.
My name is Maria Campos.
I am a mother of a student at Prepa
Tech High School.
for the renewal of Prepatec High School.
For me and my daughter Prepatec High School
is very important for the school to continue.
This is what our community needs not just
for my daughter but for the rest of the students.
They have excellent teachers.
They have the IB program which is extremely important.
For me and for the community the renewal of this school
is extremely important so that they continue
to prepare our students.
So that they can go to the university.
This is their future. The future is within our youth.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
Good morning.
Good morning. Please say your name and affiliation.
And don't forget to pause to be able to translate.
Okay. My name is Esther Garcia.
My name is Esther Garcia.
I am thankful with God and for Prepatec for helping my daughter
and getting her best potential with regards to her education.
For me Prepatec, all of the school staff and teachers
provide their best efforts so that students
provide their best efforts.
Teachers prepare students very well for life
and for university which is what concerns me the most.
I want my daughter to go to a university
and they do a great job at it.
It would be a terrible loss for students
if Prepatec High School was not renewed.
So I please beg that you renew Prepatec High School.
My daughter is very excited for what is to come
with with regards to universities
and I am very excited for her as well.
So if Prepatec High School closes down
this would be a big loss for her.
That's time caller.
Hello caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
Are you there caller?
Yes the caller with the number 2089 on the line.
Yes hi my name is Leticia Bernal.
I have a student at Prepatec
and I would like to say to you to consider
the renewal for the Bermuda Prepatec.
So they can keep teachers and workers there.
Their teachers are amazing and they provide good work
for the kids.
They help my kids through the work
and if you dismiss the opportunity
the kids are going to go like unfortunate
and I would like you to keep their dreams up.
I would like you to know to permit please.
Thank you so much.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
Hello.
We can hear you caller please begin.
My name is Jenci Baroccio.
I have two students at Prepatec a high school
and a junior high.
I would like to for you guys to touch your heart
and renew the school.
Come closer we still need the school open.
My daughter is doing great.
They help her a lot.
They have good teachers good staff.
And they have control over the kids.
Please renew the school for five years more.
Don't close it.
Touch your heart and donate to students without school.
Thank you for hearing us.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
Hello hello my name is Jimmy Luna.
I'm a senior student from Prepatec high school
and I've been with it for all the four years
and I can tell you with confidence
that the school is worth keeping open.
You know I'm not exactly sure what the situation here
and I don't know what it's costing
but I can tell you one thing
and that's that you can't put in a price on education
that builds leadership in human beings.
Prepatec is an IB school
and it's different than the rest of the schools
and that's what makes it great.
Students are shown they are more than a score in a system
and they are shown they are human beings
that can change the world for the better.
Prepatec must be kept open as the choice is bigger than me
than my friends and all of us really
as it's the type of choice that the type of decision
that decides where our future in this country lies.
The decision that changes our future.
Do we want society who advances and grows
or do we want society that is never willing to change
especially its educational system.
Today we are deciding what type of schools
we want our children to graduate from
and stop being children to become adults.
Closing the school that teaches our children
what it means to be an adult
and what it means to be a good human being
what it means to contribute to society
is the wrong decision.
You can't build a country out of workers.
You need leaders.
Hello caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
Hi my name is Andrea Gavez
and I'm a senior at Prepatec High School
and Prepa has helped me in so many ways
and the teachers here are amazing
and they do everything in their power to see us succeed.
I am now going to graduate and I'm going to college.
Prepa has changed me
and I see myself growing as a person.
Thank you.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
This is Katlyn O'Halloran
with the Charter Schools Development Center.
CSDC supports the renewal of Prepatec.
New charter schools often struggle financially
as they get established.
Our review of the school's current financials
show that they now appear to have sound fiscal footing.
CSDC commends Prepatec on achieving authorization
for the international baccalaureate diploma program
because it's a rarity in low income areas.
As a new school Prepatec has only one year
of academic state indicator data
and we know this is not much to go on.
Renewal would let the school establish a track record
and provide continuity rather than forcing a school change
on students already highly affected by the pandemic.
We also want to alert you
that we're seeing a disturbing trend
where authorizers rely solely on comparisons
of schools to state averages.
This sets up schools like Prepatec,
schools that bring in many students with low baselines
to appear poor performing
irrespective of actual student growth.
Thank you.
Thank you caller.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi, my name is Robert Bates
and I teach both history and world religions
here at Prepatec.
This is a wonderful school.
It allows students to get college credit
while in high school in two year long programs
like the ones I teach.
These programs are coordinated with all the other classes
through a theory of knowledge class
in which they learn how to learn.
It would be a shame if the school is closed
because I see so many young people moving on to college,
moving on to very good colleges because of this program.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you, caller.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Good morning board members.
My name is Marcy Messon.
I'm a proud staff member at the Prepatec High School
who started off as a pair of volunteer over 10 years ago.
I've lived in this community for and nearby communities
for over 40 years in my life.
I just want to remind everyone the reason
for the schools exist in the first place
is due to the schools in our communities failing us
and our children for decades until some parents
and teachers who actually cared about the students
decided to take matters into their own hands
and create better schools for our communities.
My kids whom my oldest daughters are over 20 years old
attended the failing public schools nearby
and I volunteered to them.
What I saw in my volunteer experience was that the LAUSD
didn't care about the students they were appointed to serve.
After hearing about charter schools I was so relieved
that my children won't finally be attending schools
that were safe and actually cares about their students.
The International Baccalaureate program here
teaches positive character building skills as well
as has a vigorous curriculum to help our children
achieve their dreams.
Thank you.
Thank you for your time.
Hello caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello.
My name is Anthony Quiones.
I'm a teacher at Prepa Tech.
Prepa Tech is unique.
Most charter schools just find a building for their students
or they rent something.
Prepa Tech went the extra mile to find a facility
make that a home for our students.
This should not be the undoing of their program.
We've improved our finances in recent years
and frankly even though students can go to other schools
they cannot achieve the same experience that they get
Thank you.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Are you there caller?
Hi. Yes I am.
Hello.
Good morning members of the State Board of Education.
My name is Dean Higley and I am the science teacher
at Prepa Tech High School.
I'm calling to urge you to reauthorize
Prepa Tech High School.
As a science teacher having a functioning lab
stations is essential for conducting labs safely
and correctly.
Labs are the practical application of science concepts
and provide hands-on opportunities
to make science come to life.
Prior to working at Alta Public Schools
I worked at three other charter schools
and in none of those was there a functioning lab station.
If students needed water for a lab
they would have to go to the restroom to go get that water.
Not a good situation.
However at Prepa Tech fully functional lab stations
were installed.
This shows Mr. Reyes's and Alta Public Schools dedication
to providing world-class education
to the Prepa Tech High School students.
Alta Public Schools is deeply concerned with making sure
students have every opportunity available to increase learning
and they put their money where their mouth is to assure this.
Thank you for your time.
Have a good day.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Good morning.
My name is Michael Jubas speaking on behalf
of the California Teachers Association.
CTA supports CDE's recommendation to not renew
Prepa Tech Los Angeles High.
While CDE's position matches the local district's decision
to not renew the petition there is still concern
that the CDE's approach to renewals of SBE authorized
charters is undermining the authority granted
by the state legislator to the local district
during the renewal process.
In December 2020 the board of LAUSD unanimously voted
to deny Prepa Tech's renewal position
and the district staff laid out several findings
that supported denying the renewal.
Additionally LAUSD submitted a notice of violation
to Prepa Tech in October 2020.
CTA believes that under AB 1505 the legislature intended
for it to be the local district's duty to conduct
a thorough and comprehensive review of these renewals.
Thank you caller.
Your time is up.
Hello caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi can you hear me.
You can hear you caller.
Hi my name is Elta Ochoa.
I'm the proud one and only assistant principal
of Prepa Tech High School and I recommend
our charter school renewal.
Our team is committed to providing a quality education
too and narrowing the education the achievement
gap for our students.
Last year our graduation rate was 89.3 percent.
Meanwhile the state was 86.6 percent.
This number illustrates the hard work our teachers do
to scaffold and personalize our students' learning
in our small class sizes.
Our educators are invested in this community and equity
for our students who are predominantly Latino
and low income.
It is important to note that our school has primarily
spent its budget on facilities and personnel.
This shows that we are person-centered
and invest in the future.
We can fully remedy our financial situation but you
cannot fix the repercussions of a denial today.
Reminder we are in a global pandemic.
Closing our school will devastate 400 Prepa Tech
staff and students along with all of our ALTA students
who look forward to doing their education with us.
Thank you.
Hello caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi this is Dr.
Sharisa Vitter.
Professor Ivey Education.
According to the Ivey school site California has only
a handful of continuum Ivey programs.
Prepa Tech is the culmination of this program
and the incorporation of the CB will make it the first
in the state.
The core of the international baccalaureate is learning
how to learn which gives students agency over
their own learning.
Ivey students are known to be problem solvers,
critical thinkers making them successful for university
or the workforce.
As for university acceptance Caltech has an 8% acceptance
rate that accepts 23.8% of Ivey students.
University of California Los Angeles has an 18% acceptance
rate but 41.4% of Ivey students.
University of California San Diego with a 35.9% acceptance
rate takes 60.7% of Ivey students.
Since there is a continuum and Prepa Tech is the culmination
2020 we looked at PYP schools to find a greater impact
on social emotional learning.
NYP students are 34% more likely to take advanced courses
in high school.
And California's programs are serving low income students.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Are you there caller?
Caller with a phone number ending with 9314.
This is your turn.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Is it me?
It is you.
Hi my name is Maurice Nicholson.
I'm a parent.
I have a daughter that I planned on going to Prepa Tech
next semester so I'm just hoping the school gets renewed.
I want to say thank you and have a great day.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi my name is Sarah Tuxbury.
I'm a Marin County resident and I want to say
that your review process for Prepa Tech
and the two other SBE authorized charters
is broken, inconsistent, and prejudicial.
You selectively use or ignore AB 1505.
Ms. Saez said yesterday that the CDE did not use
the district reports at all so I don't understand
why you make them do a review which is very expensive
and waste district resources.
You approved the Ross Valley charter
which is really no different than Prepa Tech.
They both rely heavily on debt so I'd like to ask you
to pause your reviews and fix your process
and make it more consistent and fair.
Thank you.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Are you there caller?
Hello is this the caller 3916?
This is 3916 yes.
Hello my name is Kaye Reinhart.
I'm a special ed teacher at Prepa Tech Middle School.
I had the privilege to be the DIS counselor
for special ed students after high school.
This school is more committed to students
and their progress than any school I've
worked with in 30 years.
The IB program offers them opportunities
that are not afforded to students in this area
and I urge you to please consider special ed students
and all students in this area and to keep Prepa Tech
open for another five years.
I've never worked with more committed educators
and I'm just in shock that it would even be considered
to close this school.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi my name is Yvonne Tenejas.
I'm the parent of the student at Prepa Tech High School
who have attended up to school since they first opened.
As an educator myself education is very important to me
and my family.
Finding a quality high school is very difficult task
in this community.
Finding one is a blessing and Prepa Tech has been a blessing
for my community and my family.
Its exceptional IB program has prepared my children
for higher education.
The teachers and staff are amazing.
Consequently it was a dream of Mr.
Ray's and all of those who make this possible
that have worked so hard to give our children this blessing.
Please I ask that you will please keep the school open
and be part of the success of our children in our community.
Otherwise you would be showing us that you don't really care
to give us the opportunity to give our children
higher education.
Thank you.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello my name is Elias Carrera and I'm a senior
and I just want to say that I this school right here
is has given me the opportunity to not only grow
from education but also in life as well.
And I can only I can't imagine you know this school
being closed down for future generations
that have been in my position Latino in this community
to not have this opportunity such as myself.
And this school has given me an opportunity to go
to places that I could never have imagined back then.
I always imagined I would have to go to community college
and et cetera but now I'm going to Cal State Lane going
on to even an internship for NASA and et cetera.
And I honestly just the school has given me things
like TOK which has allowed me to question
and also view life in a different perspective
and different manner of being as well.
And the teachers beyond care for us as students as well
and not only for education but also for our personal
lives as well.
And I I wish and I hope that this school can be renewed
so that others in the future in my position can also be
have this opportunity as well.
Please thank you thank you.
I beg you please help me.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi can you hear me.
Yes caller we can hear you.
Please begin.
Hi good morning my name is Yesena Guerrero.
I am a parent of a student in our sister school
Academia Moderna Elementary.
He and my family moved from the San Fernando Valley
to Los Angeles to be able to have our son attend
a school that offers the IB primary program.
Even though he has been doing school we assume
we have been pleased with his academic achievements
and progress and may I add he has been blessed
with one of the most amazing kindergarten teachers
Mrs. Bello.
I would like for my son to have the opportunity
of having an IB education from elementary all the way
up to his senior year of high school.
Please don't shut our dreams of a higher education
in a low income area that is so well needed.
That is one of the reasons why our funder Mr.
Javier Reyes has invested in our programs that touch
an early age for our kids so they can have a higher chance
of success and become who they want to be in life.
Full of confidence and very knowledgeable and nothing less.
I am asking to please renew our school our community
parents and most importantly our students our future
and future generations that are having a better education.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi my name is Matthew Welles and I'm a science teacher
at Prebacat High School.
I'm calling to support the renewal of the school.
Like the caller said before a science lab is necessary
for our students to obtain that edge over students
in LA USD and other charter schools and with the
completion of our new science lab we now have all
the necessary materials for our students to be successful
academically in the sciences.
So I would encourage you to please renew Prebacat High
School and support our students developing science
as they continue to conduct research and do other
experiments that will give them an edge over the rest
of the community.
Thank you.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Are you there caller.
Hello.
Yes I am here.
Hi my name is Glenda Ademan.
I'm one of the directors here at Alta Public Schools
and I want to urge the board to renew Prebatec Los Angeles.
The CDE and LA USD presenters have brought up concerns
about Prebatec's historical financials.
I want to affirm that our leadership staff takes
the financial health of the organization very seriously
and we meet often to discuss our financial situation
and how to improve our bottom line.
You can see this commitment in that our financials
are improving rapidly.
We have had to make hard decisions about what to cut
to improve our financials without hurting our
students' education.
The CDE and LA USD has stated that we do not demonstratively
show the ability to manage our financials.
However I believe this to be untrue.
We have contracted with financial experts who work
with many other successful charter schools who support us.
In addition our two other schools do not demonstrate
similar financial issues.
Thus there is capacity to run a fiscally solvent program.
Again I urge the board to renew Prebatec Los Angeles.
Thank you caller.
Your time is now.
To continue providing a much needed education.
Thank you.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello my name is Lauren and I'm a senior at Prebatec
and I strongly urge you to renew our school.
Someone mentioned the closure of the school is in the best
interest of the students and as a student I strongly disagree.
IB program while groundbreaking and innovative
has historically been for students in affluent areas.
But Prebatec is bringing this program to underserved youth
and is providing us with opportunities we could never
imagine.
I never thought I could meet with official United Nations
ambassadors all the way in New York or receive
the Congressional Gold Medal the only youth award provided
by the United States Congress.
And I never thought I would end up I'm an elite top 20
school Duke University and Prebatec prepared me
for all of those things and so much more.
If the main reason why you don't support the reopening
of the school is money then I respectfully ask you
to reevaluate what you value in the school.
Prebatec is lifting up our community and there are no
schools like it.
Our community needs Prebatec.
Thank you very much for your time.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello caller are you there.
What number.
Ending number is 3415.
Hi good morning.
My name is Sylvia Nicholson.
I'm the office manager of Prebatec High School.
I have the privilege to be working here at Prebatec
High School.
It's a great school.
Prebatec High School prepared the students for the best
education.
Our community needs this school.
We have an IB program that no other school has.
Prebatec IB programs matter in this community.
Our students and family are very happy at Prebatec High School.
We work hard to receive the diploma program started
for our students at Prebatec.
Please give us the renewal.
Our community really needs this school to stay open
for another five years.
It would be a great loss if this school is not renewed.
Please let us continue to give the great education
to our children.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello good morning.
My name is Gabrielle Kurtz.
I'm a senior at Prebatec Los Angeles High School.
I would like to request that Prebatec stay open
simply because of the opportunities
that are available to us there.
The IB program that is not offered at any other school
near me and many others has taught me many skills
and advanced my learning enough so that I feel confident
in my journey to higher level education.
Even though this course is rigorous my teachers
have been able to support me and many of my peers
in their struggles.
After my four years of attending Prebatec
I can confidently say that I have never met
my dedicated and caring teachers.
They've gone above and beyond for their students
even during this pandemic.
I'm now going to a four-year university
in which most of my tuition is covered by scholarships.
This is thanks to the opportunities available
at my high school.
I will be forever grateful for this.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello are you speaking to the phone number 7619.
We are caller.
I'm not guarding yet but I think this would go a lot smoother
if you just said the last four digits of each number.
Caller your time is already ticking
so please begin your message.
Well one of the core values is that you have to be
communication and many of my students brought up sentiments
that the translator was misrepresenting significant
messages from our Spanish speaking population.
I thought that should be communicated.
I'm starting now with my main point.
I'm the mock teacher for the IB program.
Caller you have 44 seconds remaining.
Which is severely limited in scope unimaginative
and neglecting a great deal of extremely important skills
not offered in the course I teach for mathematics.
If you disband this charter you're leading the future
generation on a on a bleak and dismal path towards darkness.
I'm a data scientist with five years experience
in the aerospace industry and a software developer.
I'm aware of the skills L.A. USC has done a terrible job
of placing into the high school curriculum.
Programming is non-existent.
Nobody does any data research.
My math students chose investigative topics
independently and they created 12 to 20 pages reports
incorporating actual data collection analysis
of their results and they made their own inferences
and conclusions about many topics including coronavirus
deforestation crime rates in L.A.
So how many high school students are you testing
on their ability to creatively apply mathematics
and interpret the complex variations
inherent in real world data.
That's my question for you.
Thank you.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Caller ending with seven three four nine.
Are you on the line.
Yes.
Hi.
Good morning.
My name is Jose Mendoza and I'm a math teacher
at Prevotek High School.
I'm calling in to voice my support in keeping
the school open because of one major aspect
and that is our school promotes growth.
In the two years that I have been working at the school
I have seen growth in all areas for my students teachers
administrators and myself.
The school actively promotes growth in several different ways
but some of them include the IB curriculum
having high expectations to both students and staff
and most importantly provides the resources tools
and support needed to advance the individual
and learner to that higher level.
The school is on a course for greatness
and by closing it down now will be a disservice
to our community.
Please vote to keep Prevotek High School open.
Thank you.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Caller ending with two seven four three.
Are you there caller?
All callers that are on the line for public comment
for Prevotek Los Angeles High please know that when
it is your time to speak for public comment
that the line will tell you that you are being unmuted
and that is your prompt to begin your public comment.
Hello caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Caller ending with five three five three.
Are you on the line?
Hello caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Caller ending.
Good morning board member.
My name is Karina Gongora.
I am a special education teacher at Prevotek Los Angeles
High School.
I am also a proud team member and in support of the renewal
of Prevotek Los Angeles High School for a few reasons.
One Prevotek Los Angeles High School teachers are leaders
who are making a positive and transformative impact
in the lives of our students in this community.
Prevotek Los Angeles High School is unique
in that it offers students in the southeast community
an opportunity to experience academic learning
and personal growth as well as global social responsibility
through the IB program.
The IB program acknowledges the changing histories of students.
Barriers to learning and assessments are not restricted
to those with a statement of needs.
Inclusion is important.
And inclusion is facilitated in the culture of collaboration
mutual respect support and problem solving
involving our whole school community.
As a special education teacher I'm proud to say
that the majority of our senior class students are enrolled
in community colleges or in the process of attending
a trade school.
Students are participating in job readiness programs.
Your time is up.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for your time.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Am I on.
Caller ending in three eight nine five.
It is your turn.
Thank you.
My name is Uriel Quiones and I teach theory of knowledge.
Board members are at promise students are now at risk
of losing their school.
While other states argue about the policies
whether to include critical race theory and school curriculum
IB schools such as Prepa Tech High School offer courses
such as theory of knowledge which provide the opportunity
for students to reflect on the nature of knowledge itself.
These are our future leaders.
The resilience of our students and faculty coupled
with our high college acceptance graduation rates
should overshadow the physical numbers that have already
been addressed.
We're not asking for a bailout we're asking for renewal
of a school.
I ask this highly educated board to remember your training
your schooling your pedagogy.
At the end of the day we should be listening
to our students and community.
Do not let our students be forced to attend California
public schools that have gone from first to worst.
All students deserve equal access to high quality education.
We are providing that for our students.
Look at our grad rates.
Look at our college acceptance rates.
But most importantly look at the community we are building.
A point of clarification for callers who want to make
public comment we are able to see if somebody is calling
in multiple times from the same number.
It is our policy that each caller has one minute
for public comment and we ask that you respect that.
Caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Excuse me for a minute.
Let's have our Spanish translator repeat those
instructions about calling in only once and that we can see
the number.
That's important.
Gracias.
Okay go ahead Carolyn.
Thank you.
Caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Caller 2532 it is your turn.
Good afternoon.
My name is Isabel Contreras and the reason that I am calling
this is to support Prepatec High School.
I've been listening to all the comments that I have been making
and I know that LAUSD does have schools to offer our families
but unfortunately our families want an IB school.
An IB school that has been open in our community for once
and is giving our kids an opportunity to success
to a great future.
We want the students to understand that being prepared
for life matters.
It's not just what you are being taught through books.
As a community member for so many years within Wano Park,
Cunningham Park and Bell I can tell you we've been waiting
for so many years for a great school and now that we have
this school that is a startup school has only been around
for a couple of years.
You want to take it away?
Why not support a school for once?
Why not be behind the school and make it better?
This is making a change in our community for once.
Thank you caller.
Your time is up.
Hello caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Caller ending in 2963.
This is your turn.
Hi.
Good morning.
I am Angelica Limon and I'm a parent educator
for Perpatec Middle School.
I'm calling on behalf of the Perpatec High School.
I truly, I'm sorry, I truly believe that high school
is in there in our community.
Perpatec High School is the only IB school in our region.
Our students deserve a school with an IB program.
This is a good opportunity for them and it will be better
to prepare them for an after high school education.
I ask you please consider that Perpatec High School
is known for a better future.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello.
Can you hear me?
We can hear you caller.
Thank you.
Hi.
My name is Alexis Sanchez and I am an 11th grader
at Perpatec High School.
I'm speaking today to ask for the renewal of my school.
I have been a part of all the public schools
since I was five years old.
Attending since kinder, the school has changed
my life for the better.
I have been offered numerous amount of opportunities
that no other school could provide for me.
I have been given so much support from the teachers
that I am beyond grateful for.
At Perpatec, I feel happy and genuinely cared for.
I know all my teachers have my best interest at heart.
I have learned so many things because of Prepa.
The learning environment motivates me to become better
and grow each and every day.
I am currently enrolled in the IBDP program.
This program is a two-year course that will provide
so many benefits for my future.
If the renewal to my school is not granted,
many of us will not be able to finish our DP course
since it is a two-year course throughout
junior and senior year.
Please give the renewal to Perpatec High School.
There's people against our renewal but they have no idea
how it would affect us.
They have not seen the help and assistance
that Perpatec provides for us.
They have not seen the doors that Perpatec has opened for us.
Our community wouldn't be the same without it.
I ask from the bottom of my heart that you approve
the renewal of Perpatec High School.
I can't thank you enough for all my life shutting down.
Thank you for.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Caller ending in 9314.
This is your turn.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
My name is Ines Santana and I am here today to ask you
to please renew Perpatec High School.
Perpatec High School's early investments have paid off
and it clearly shows in the acceptance of students
now attend great universities.
My children and the community deserve a better opportunity
and Perpatec High School is here to provide that
with the international baccalaureate program.
Earlier a gentleman from LAUSD board shared that they have
an extensive plan to find schools for the families
and emphasize the IB program.
This is a much easier step than done.
It will be very hard for our families to travel to Hawthorne,
Asianta Heights and Granada Hills where there are the other
IB programs exist.
I have two children and there is no way I would be able
to make that commute.
There is a school in downtown LA and it is a magnet school.
And you and I know that it is very difficult to enter
a magnet school.
And for the record the majority of IB families that I know
are here today because they were not able to get into
an IB into a magnet program.
Please renew Perpatec High School.
Our kids deserve the best.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Caller ending in 8 0 3 3.
This is your time.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi.
Good morning board members.
My name is Lupe Mendez employee of Alta Public School
since 2009.
I am here to support and ask that Perpatec be renewed.
Aside from providing a rigorous IB program we provide a safe
and family oriented environment.
A place where the students feel welcomed loved supported
and safe.
We have built great relationships with our students
parents and community.
Throughout my years with Alta it has been a blessing to see
the growth in our students in all areas.
As a former LEUSD student quite some time ago I wish I would
have had the experience that our students currently have
at Perpatec High and our sister schools.
Hard work pays off.
Along with our parents we are extremely proud of all
of our students and graduating students that were accepted
to prestigious universities.
If that doesn't demonstrate the dedication of teachers
leaders administrators staff students and parents
then I am at a loss of words.
Without the renewal this would be detrimental to our students.
Thank you Paola your time is up.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi my name is Gilbert Hernandez and I am currently
a junior at Perpatec.
I have been with with the Alta family since its sister
school Alguerame Moderna first opened in 2009.
The school offers a unique IB education that teaches
students to seek more in their education.
I strongly urge you to renew Perpatec as we encourage
the students to become not only better learners
in the classroom but also outside of the classroom
to become better members of society.
If you shut down the school you will be sending these kids
into into a worse education and into probably delinquency
and you and I both don't want that so please I urge
you to please renew Perpatec High School.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Caller ending in 7349.
This is your turn.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Caller ending in 7619.
Your time is now.
Hi I just wanted to say that the typical LA math course
teaches things that students never use and they get turned
off by it and the IB curriculum teaches them how to apply math
to real world situations and I don't understand if you're
going to get rid of this school what is the point of teaching
like the regular LA USC curriculum which has rational roots
of polynomials that no one ever uses and a lot of students
across LA just to test math because they don't ever use it
for anything but the math course in the IB program is called
applications and interpretation and if you're testing students
on things that don't matter well how are you comparing apples
to oranges because what they learn here I've seen students
do amazing things with math and solve problems that are
relative to their life.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello my name is Michelle Solorzano.
I am a family teacher at Prebatec Los Angeles High School.
This has been my school for the past five years and within
these years I see firsthand the academic progress
of the school and students.
This year alone we have seniors accepted to Cal State
UC's and even Duke University to name a few.
What we are doing for our students is providing
them with a world-class education and the academic
tools to be able to be accepted to these colleges
and to be ready for the real world that awaits them.
Our students will graduate as lifelong learners as well
as men and women of character.
To see the school close will be heartbreaking for our students
staff and community.
I highly recommend that you approve Prebatec Los Angeles
High School for school renewal.
Thank you.
Thank you caller.
That concludes our public comment for this item.
So given there are no other public comments I hereby close
the public hearing at 1139 a.m.
And I just want to thank all the callers who took the time
to call in the staff, the parents, the community,
students, everybody who was part of it.
I think the board listened very closely and we are now
going to begin our board discussion.
So first I'd like to ask our board liaison Sue Burr
and Ting Sung if they would like to make some initial
comments and then following that we'll turn to board
discussion.
Remember board members if you use the raised hand
I'll be sure to call on you.
So thank you.
Member Burr and Sung.
Thank you Vice President Strau.
Before I make my comments I think Stephanie Farland
might have a clarification on something from the
presentations.
Oh I just thank you member Sung.
I had heard and maybe I misunderstood but in the
charter schools presentation when they talked about some
of the struggles they had fiscally when they first
started the school upon startup that they didn't have
any startup funds.
But we did they did receive a $575,000 implementation
grant federal grant that our department manages.
And so I just wanted to clarify that because I thought
that's what he said like I said I might have misunderstood
that I wanted to put that out there that that grant was
available to them and they applied and got that in 2016.
Thank you.
Okay thank you.
Yeah so yeah again echoing Vice President Strau's
comments thank you to the public who testified
especially the students and parents.
It you know it's always is difficult in looking at these
charter renewals and knowing that they will be impacting
people's lives.
So I hear you at the same time I have still have some
concerns.
This school has the issues regarding especially the
fiscal issues have been consistent.
But the responses and the level of response to those
concerns have not been consistent in that they don't
seem like they have been addressed very seriously until
up until maybe even this point.
When these appeals come to us the charter has three major
stabs if you will at addressing concerns.
And at the at the district level and then at the ACCS
and then coming to here I do not did not hear of anything
about any kind of austerity plan or any major mitigation
to the to the financial issues up until this point today.
And I will have some additional questions when we get
to the question part but just wanted to put out there
that I still have some concerns.
Member Burr did you want to make some comments?
Yeah I think my comments are largely along the lines of
board member Sun.
Let me again also say thank you to everyone who called in.
It's clear that there's strong feelings in support of the
school by especially by parents and students that we
heard from but unfortunately I feel like our responsibility
is to sort of twofold it's both for academic performance
and also financial integrity.
And again just to reinforce what board member Sun said
we have overseen this school meaning the state board of
education for five years and for five years we have seen
consistent problems with financial issues.
Stephanie and Farland laid that out carefully and I don't I
didn't feel confident in the presentation that was made
that they actually have been addressed and I also have to
say that in my deliberations about charters I am always
influenced greatly by what our own advisory commission says
and in the case of the advisory commission on this school
they voted unanimously to deny the renewal and they
they considered it very carefully and as I think you all
know the majority of people who are sit on the advisory
commission are actually charter school operators or they're
in oversight agency so I take with great consideration what
the advisory commission says so I'm looking forward to hearing
what other board members have but at this point I'm not
inclined to renew this school.
Thank you member Burr.
I have a couple of questions that I'd like to start the
conversation with and first this is to LA Unified to Dr.
Perry and your team so Dr. Perry thanks for being with us
yet it's been a while since we'd seen you before so the
first question is and I know this because I live in the
Los Angeles area that LA Unified had generally made a
commitment to not close charters during the pandemic
and we heard that you at least say that you originally
recommended conditional approval.
We were curious why and where the board disagreed with that
original recommendation how that evolved.
The steps board vice president Strauss were as follows when
our team analyzed the data in the months that we had to do
it our staff internal recommendation was denied the
pandemic then because now under 1505 we have a much longer
time the pandemic raged on and when we began to talk with our
leadership about that that was a feeling because ultimately
it's our superintendent's recommendation we're staff and
we provide our best work to him and then he then provides
that recommendation to the board and it was that you know
what we don't know what's about to happen you know let's call
a halt on that however when it got to the board level there
was considerable discussion and it really revolved around
what board member Sun and board member Burr were just
discussing plans that weren't plans you know no path forward
and this is not a new school you know this organization has
been you know you can say it's a new school because this is
their new but the organization's been around a while
and one would expect the ability to create a plan
particularly a financial plan that was stronger we even had
discussions of the finances with the renewal of one of the
other schools it was a very difficult renewal because we had
to dig into the finances so I hope I answered your question the
board looked at that they looked at schools in the area and how
those schools were doing and ultimately made the decision that
in the best interest of students and in the you know in adhering to
the education code that it would be recommendation for denial and
they voted and Ms. Farland shared what that vote was thank you I
have another question for you before I ask a CD question so we
heard a lot of commitment to the IB program and how parents
valued it they drive for that program we certainly heard from
the staff and students certainly how students are prepared and
and how they that's a unique opportunity so if the CD
recommendation is upheld to close it how are you going to think
about students and how they'd be supported in LAUSD to transition
because we worry about continuity particularly now
and we've heard that there's not as many IB programs so
what is the I know your team has thought about this what is the
plan if the school should close right I'll speak first and then
turn to our director who has also been in contact and together
I think we can give you a full picture first of all what our
team does as I indicated before we have we have a lot of
experience with this not so much in denials but more in self
closures we have a quite a few of those so we have a process
that we go through and the first one always has to be a
transcript analysis we need to look at where those students are
and what they need not only transcripts we need to look at
IPs we've spoken with our division of special education
who stands ready to pull the IP data and begin to look at that
and decide where the appropriate placement for those students
will be we have a number of types of programs that students
will will be afforded an opportunity to go to Mr.
Cole Gutierrez would you fill in for this thank you Dr.
Perry and oh good morning to you all and more to vice president
Strauss thank you for asking that important question in
addition to what Dr. Perry shared we've had already
detailed conversations respectfully knowing that the
state makes the final decision but in preparation with our
colleagues in our local districts in this community as
well as surrounding communities looking at several school
options the process of contacting families with the
support of CDE staff the transcript analysis that Dr.
Perry mentioned looking at IB programs in the area
there are high school IB programs in the area some of
them are about six miles from the location we did hear of
some parents driving from other areas to for this school
there are others in in proximate areas it still may be a bit of a
of a drive but there are more options than the ones that were
cited in in Hacienda Heights and Granada Hills etc.
In short board members staff's commitment is to have an
individualized approach families will have their choices from
district programs and and always we also share other
programs in the area whether they're LA Unified authorized
charter school programs so they have the full
array of options available to them and we will then
support them to see which best fit their child's needs again I
reiterate never an easy decision we honor that we honor those voices
but also seek to to support the appropriate
following of the law and accountability wherever that's
being necessary so you can count on our commitment
to provide that individualized service and to help families make their choices.
Thank you my last question before I turn it to other board members
this is to Stephanie Farland from CD and then I'm going to be asking
Prepatech to respond to the English language development program it's been
really important in California to look at integrated
and designated support for English learners I believe this
school serves a large English learner population
we've continued to evaluate that in our review
of charters first Stephanie I believe and I'd like you to review that that the
CD did not find the English language development
program adequate to meet the needs and then I'd like
Prepatech to respond on what the actual program is
so please Stephanie if you can address that that'd be helpful.
Yes thank you so what we found was they do have an intervention program
and their intervention program from all accounts seems to be adequate
what they don't have is they don't have a curriculum
and if I remember correctly and I wasn't here at the time so I think this is
correct but when they were approved last go around by the state board that
was one of the things that they needed to
correct and and they haven't and so I'm not sure
why they haven't done that yet and and I think there may I don't know
there's some confusion around whether the intervention program is
the curriculum but program but according to our special
ed division staff who reviewed this they they do
not have a standards aligned curriculum for their school and I'm sure they can
they can talk about what their program is or does but that's what we have found
is that they do have an intervention program
they but we're not sure if it's standard standards
aligned because they don't have an actual curriculum that standards align
to put school thank you Stephanie so I appreciate the
explanation so I'll ask prepatech and I'm not sure
which I know we have several representatives from prepatech
about what the English language development program is for all students
and if you want to expand and explain the
intervention it's a critical issue for us particularly
in student support that have English learner needs so
we'd appreciate if somebody from prepatech would be willing
to address that I don't know if Mr. Aguirre are you the one that's going to
address it I can address it and this via logos
can chime in one of the things that is clear with
our ivy program the the the premise of ivy is
international and so they offer one of the two the
things that is part of the ivy program is the dual
language meaning developing our students with a
primary language which is in many cases English
but in other cases for English learners it is Spanish that's their primary
language developing that language at the same time
they're developing the other language the language what they
call in ivy world the language B and so the language B
would be their secondary language and that's how
we structured our program we use read 180
as a tool for our students to be able to
use a technology current technology for their acquisition of the English
language they one of the things that
is is embedded within the ivy is where their units as they develop the
units there are the EL standards that need
to be addressed and teachers indicate that in their unit
development you manage that where teachers enter create their
unit and within that they have their content
standards as well as the ELD standards that they are to address within the
students within their classes and so that is
what's what we do within our students and so then the
other thing is they have the ELD path where the teachers work with the two of
the read 180 and align that with the
ELD standard in order to address the development of the language
English language acquisition. Thank you for the explanation. Is
Mavia Lobos going to also clarify I just want to make sure if she
hi good evening thank you so much I'm unable to share my video so excuse me
for that it says that the host is not allowing me at this time so I'm
sorry but just to kind of further what
Mr. Aguirre said is oh thank you so much thank you
and just to reiterate what we stated is
we do absolutely have recognized that at the beginning of the history for
Puppetik High School that there was a little bit of an
issue with that and so the first thing that we did when
we came on board it's going to now be three years of new
administration is we identified that administration
first and foremost has to be part of the multi-lingual support division
and we participate in the English language roadmap project for example
to be able to strengthen our English learners
program. The next step that we took is we also compared
how IB standards and the spoken sequence of
IB correlates with the California English Language
Development Framework as well as the English language
standards so once we were able to identify that
then we made sure that the MTSS process came into effect to ensure
that we had and we viewed both the designated ELD
as well as the integrated ELD utilizing also the state's
what is it called the state's
I guess I think this is the ICEP for you know from the state which is the
individual student assessment disability profile
in the beginning of the discussions to know
where we're placing our skills once they come into
to prepatech history. Thanks so much for the clarification so I'm going to turn
to other board members now for any clarifying questions
for CDE for the for the LA Unified or for prepatech.
Go ahead.
So for CDE staff Stephanie you had mentioned that
in the latest proposal of financials that there was an additional 22
students or something was that added for this year?
Thank you member Sen. Well based on their analysis and all you know
we obviously didn't have a lot of time to dig into this since we just got it
this week but it did seem like in the March report
prior to ACCS there were 334 students in the May report there were 356
listed which is a difference of 22
and so I I'm not sure where that difference came from if it was a
typo if it I so I like I said there wasn't a
lot of explanation along with the different the various
changes so I don't know where it comes from.
Right and so was that to then did that then translate to the actual
budget for this year and the revise of this year's budget
that there would be because there's it's yeah go ahead yeah and I'm and I'm not
I'm not sure because they I mean what they're giving us is a new
projected budget but they use the current numbers
were just different so I like they don't they didn't
so they didn't redo their whole as far as I know and
I have my fiscal person on on the call if I'm
mucking this up but I didn't see any reason why they would currently
uh change the the numbers in current year so I could see if
they were changing enrollment projections for
future years for the next five years but in terms of the report that we
received this week they actually had a difference in current year numbers
um and I just and there would no explanation member sun as to
why um why that was uh so there was uh
so that would be a good question for them are my fiscal
person um is saying that this there was no budget assumption for the may report
most of the revenue remained the same so I'm really not sure why
those numbers changed okay if it's enrollment but then
increase but then the budget numbers didn't change for that year it's
it's fine because it's hold harmless this year anyway
so their their their um enroll numbers would not
impact any of their um their ada because they're held
held harmless this year so it's okay well I guess part of the issue just is
is that the enrollment numbers never have been what they were supposed to be
if you look at the at the initial petition that you all approved this
board approved um before their enrollment numbers they
were projecting over 600 students for for 2020-21 um so that's been part of
the issue um over the last several years and it's
been part of one of the concern letters that we sent earlier
in their term was that they were not meeting their enrollment numbers
okay thank you and then for la usd um uh mr perry talked about a
individualized approach to the students and making sure they're placed
and so i'm assuming that if some of these students
are eligible for an id diploma and they're a year away or two years away
that you would do the best you can to place them in a
program where they can actually receive that
the person absolutely okay thank you
so i'm looking for other board member clarifications or comments
so i don't see any hands raised so at this time um
i'll see if somebody's ready to make a motion
i would move to adopt the department's recommendation
um and i will second that i i agree with um member
er that um the accs um has a lot of sway as well having
heard um this this charter in much much even
greater detail than here
so thank you we have a motion and a second so executive director
alan would you please call the roll member burr
aye member fatah
aye member glover woods yes member mcquillan
yes member navo
member patillo brownson yes member rodriguez
yes member rucker yes member strouse vice president strouse
apologize yes member sun yes
motion passes so thank you um thank you stephanie thank
you to all of our presenters um i hereby
adjourned the may 2021 state board meeting
at 12 04 p.m thank you all for for your for your comments and your
engagement and for sharing and being part of the
discussion this morning so i look forward to seeing you all
um cdc says we may not have to wear as many our masks as much if we've been
vaccinated so looking forward to seeing more of you
all in july and wishing that everyone stays healthy and well
thank you thank you eileen thank you eileen